all right over 2 million illegal
immigrants have crossed the border since
joe biden took office historic highs and
this historic surge is even going to get
bigger because the biden administration
is about to remove the final trump-era
border policy left in place that's
called title 42 and that allows for the
instant deportation of migrants at the
border due to covet we are in the middle
of a pandemic former senior adviser to
president trump stephen miller joins us
now stephen
uh this is a no-brainer i mean i
remember we had the the cages with all
the kids in it overcrowded in the middle
of the pandemic uh and jenn saki saying
we don't need to test illegal immigrants
because they're not going to stay here
very long that was a big lie
why would they rescind this the pandemic
continues omicron 2.0 is already here in
new york city and it's about to hit the
whole country your reaction
the southern border is the
perfect place for new viruses and new
variants and new evolutions of this
disease to spread people arrive at that
border crammed into trucks crammed into
cars and tractor trailers piled on top
of each other sharing the same air it's
as dangerous as it can get from a public
health standpoint that's why president
trump put in place title 42 not only
saving thousands of lives but in the
process fully sealing the united states
southern border as we speak at this
moment we already have 7 000
apprehensions a day
most of them released into the country
at least 2 000 so-called godaways that
we know of plus many more that we don't
know of that's over 10 000 at least a
day
crossing into this country the decision
to end what's left of title 42 will turn
our border from the peace comm and total
security of the trump era into an utter
nightmare and illegal immigration
apocalypse it will be that bad sean
you know if if for example getting rid
of the trump policy joe biden he not
only brought back
uh
the policies of the obama administration
catch and release but now it's on
steroids because it's basically catch
process and
give a free ride to the state of your
choice
now if i did that or you did that i'm
pretty confident that we would get
arrested for violating the immigration
laws but more importantly we probably
would be accused of human trafficking am
i am i wrong on that correct no we would
be
no you're 100 right sean if you or i
were to transport people across state
lines let alone international boundaries
in the back of a truck or a car we'd be
in jail for years for smuggling
trafficking or kidnapping if a u.s
citizen just transports say a minor
across state lines in the back of a
truck
i mean rightly so that's a severe
severe criminal offense
just on child smuggling alone in the
first year of the abaddon administration
150 000 children were smuggled across
our borders by criminals because of this
administration's policy of everybody
gets in and everybody gets resettled
when you eliminate title 42 the last
remaining shred of immigration
enforcement it will be a truly an utter
open border with no limits at all
all right stephen miller by the way
congratulations are in order for you
and
your wife katie uh on the birth of your
new baby thank you so much sean we
couldn't be blessed we couldn't be
happier for you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else